[Music]
yeah well welcome to this video some of
my mouse was a little bit strange so
that was my me being a bit startled at
the beginning so we have a calm very
ation in the Sicilian and yeah what's
happening after Quincy seven I am that's
it yeah yeah yeah I've looked at all
this but tend to forget things so when
I'd see too how do i develop now just
like Bishop each went yeah 96-95 might
be might be an option for him ok I think
I can still do that the Queen can go to
g3 which is probably ok ok just go be
three develop yeah looks like a fairly
normal Sicilian like a hedgehog style it
doesn't have played d6 yet mmm yeah I
thought that this would actually be
annoying for him there are a couple of
whoa why why i said a move 95
let's think for one moment in a bit is
strong I mean it is stronger taking
longer would really be a waste of time
so i can take f6 now for a pawn or see
if i can find something better let's
take the pawn this is actually not ideal
strategically speaking so I was
hesitating for a moment giving him the
bishop is not not that great but the
porn is still a pawn yeah 95 it's more
more of a show-off move than anything
else doesn't do all that much
[Music]
a night only three years a little bit in
a little bit of strange spot maybe I can
play Knights you form to have six go for
this that did I failed us very weakening
but maybe I cannot exploit it but cheeky
seven Queen takes yeah but I still I
still think I want to trade 11 rook so
and where do I go with that night
actually now this is okay night h2 also
looks like a very long long journey that
doesn't lead to all that much I'm
thinking 92 f 46 that's an idea I wonder
if Queen you for as a move I'm probably
not at least not something that worries
me a lot yeah this is not nicer to have
a night on e cigs so what is he doing
here I should probably put this on e 2
and then work with discoveries check
[Music]
now let's see well 97 isn't that winning
stuff yeah that wins stuff which is not
very precise it's tough but something
you have to see actually that was
probably not helping all that much if I
go into the e-file Bishop f8 the Roku
doesn't have squares so that was kind of
a non I diem so what to do he might put
it on a five I think it's helpful if i
can get the bishops traded yeah
definitely if for so i think i can play
this
the trades off the bishop may be no
Bishop f5 I can just move the Queen IAM
and then it doesn't have a good move
yeah I can play here I think on let's
see taking 105 it's just not a good
ending yeah I think I can go here time
morning maybe queen bee 6mm at this
possible but okay I can check king of
seven bishops e6 now check
yeah but I can take you so let's just
take it and go from here there is no
meat though something maybe this is
coming maybe I can play for media Queen
III threatens look at eight create mate
could look it doesn't have a check now
and I'm threatening now who gave aid
with made into so yeah okay this is made
up check checkmate yeah sometimes you
have to play for those tricks if you are
down one time I would and I don't think
it was like playing for tricks in a
sense that he had something it was just
hoping for quicker the side of this game
yeah so he stepped into this 95 more the
NTA he has to somehow realize that
there's something amiss but in fact this
isn't like winning immediately I'm can
also switch on the engine you go yeah i
mean it is nice for white but it still
continues this game his bishop on f6 is
not bad and i don't have very active
pieces at the moment yeah maybe night f5
is what I'm considered and then go he am
that that could be something maybe that
was a bit better I don't think I've I
spoiled much him no the computer
dislikes f5 which I really understand i
think this gives gives me more more
ideas
and here it gets it gets really
uncomfortable Queenie five okay now i
cannot play 90 c ni g 6 p.m. this is a
whoops this is a blunder due to my queen
okay then that was a lot better now no
I'm getting getting into blacks position
k just with this he ignored 97 after
that it's basically over and want to
check with the after this each pawn
check business if you have some defense
no actually not the end here there's the
mate assistance is unavoidable now and
you wants to do this okay that loses the
house ok guys thanks for watching